[Music]
let's get some lost porn oh yeah big
shout out yes yes big shout out to this
twitter account coiners taking l's i've
been bros taking l's oh there's also a
fantastic interrupt there's also a
fantastic website called web 3 is going
great i think it's called yeah and it's
just blog posts about all the scams that
are happening sick yeah so yeah sorry
keep going well no so the at is coiners
taking l's and following this dude for a
little while and all of these are so
[ __ ] funny the swift reality checks
on these people get okay seeing someone
lose their nfts to a phishing scam and
then instantly uh falling for another
scam is making me lose it i got done by
this lost three of my nfts i had same
issue but i recovered it back after my
friend introduced to oh it's just like
another scam link oh yeah yeah dude says
thanks we'll reach out yeah dude devin
sent one yesterday that he saw on a
twitter thread same thing and it was
like a link to a google doc and it was
like coinbase support oh my god and it
was like all the questions were like
really official and the copy was really
well worded like it actually seemed like
a
copywriter at a tech company would write
that yeah and then the last question was
please provide your 12-word seed raise
come on
come on dude
like that is proof that crypto can't go
much further because when you get that
seed phrase how many times they say in
big bold [ __ ] text do not give this
to anybody but people forget you read
that and then you're like wait what do i
do what do i not give my private that's
what i'm saying or the seat phrase i
forget and no one's gonna write that
[ __ ] down and keep it laminated that's
why that's what i do look at this guy in
the next three months i will hire 30
lawyers at kraken fx i'd like to hire 60
but honestly i don't know how to get it
done can i acquire a law firm
always a good sign when a company asks
for help hiring as many lawyers yeah
yeah
that's a pretty good one we have no real
commentary here other than that this
account just makes you feel good um how
much do you charge for promos 1.5 eth
per tweet
who is this he's
some account sexy okay
uh crypto guy yeah do you accept the new
uh puma nfts payment worth to eth
link it and what's the link oh put
put my nuts in your mouth
and that dude's account got suspended
what is this we got here oh yeah this
whole like thing where el salvador like
bought a bunch of uh bitcoin now all
their holdings are in the red like deep
oh no yeah yeah is this crypto winter
again what's going on dude [ __ ] i
don't know this is weak it's been it's
getting hammered it's been i mean
tesla's down a [ __ ] ton too which i love
to see and world war three is about to
happen i i've gone down a rabbit hole of
like elon musk fans oh my god no this
can't be real oh here we go yeah run it
i just went through two busy airports
one full three hour airplane flight and
not one person complimented my board ape
hoodie i can't do this anymore i have
seven different hoodies and none of it
and none of and not have been noticed
yet what the hell this has to be a bit
maybe hoodies are out of style this has
to be a bit this can't be real holy [ __ ]
dude nah that's that's i mean i don't
know i've seen some pretty ladies these
are the people that we're gonna be
eating with at garyvee's restaurant
how do you do this restaurant are they
out of style sorry dude if that ends up
panning out i'm going to eat in there
and i'm going to look at the next person
and be like did you pay to sit in here
idiot and i'm just going to leave
because i just feel like we'll be
walking proof that you don't need to
have the nft to go in yeah which is i
know he has like the whole guest pass
thing but like doesn't that defeat the
purpose yeah yeah right i want to go
there yeah i mean i'll go i'll go eat
there i absolutely how great of a story
would that be it'd be hilarious yeah
sure um and who knows there is a small
chance that this idea an nft restaurant
will work yeah maybe that's the problem
with this yeah ninety percent of it you
can make fun of just like i bet in the
90s people are like what do you mean
[ __ ] toilet.com what are you talking
about like i was i was listening to uh
how i built this episode yesterday of
this guy he made good reads
you know that app to compare books no
you don't know that
you ever look a book up for reviews or
whatever it'll take you to good reads no
okay just like a good like book
recommendation engine and everything got
it his first job was for
this company called uh tickle and all
they did is make buzzfeed quizzes
what dog are you yeah yeah and i got
acquired by monster
for but imagine like then yeah like this
is so [ __ ] stupid and eventually i
guess they were like reaching so many
people that it was super valuable no
yeah i mean i i think yeah obviously so
much of nfts are [ __ ] but like the
real ones yeah there's gonna be like an
ebay like a few something is gonna
happen companies where it works
yeah but all of it is bad for the most
part oh sorry i was just gonna say i
went down this rabbit hole of like elon
fans it's so crazy how some of those
people like have sipped the kool-aid oh
yeah let's talk about the monkeys oh
yeah well the ones he killed for
knurling yeah yeah and he was like oh
you have to do unethical test testing to
bridge to ethical testing it's like uh
what dude that's like some 1920s
philosophy yeah no we have to cut the
heads off of cats and reanimate them to
see if it's possible yeah i mean
like all right so i guess if you don't
know what we're talking about these he
was testing neurolink his company which
was doing the brain chip they're doing
testing on monkeys right now and i guess
like the board of ethics or something
got involved because 70 of the monkeys
that they were testing it on killed
themselves but in brutal ways like rip
their own limbs off and [ __ ] like that
like they inserted the chip into their
brains and then they just went [ __ ]
crazy how horrible is that they just
wanted to be 25 again yeah
nice damn that took me a second that guy
is such a [ __ ] whack job
it's so funny reading um
tesla forum screenshots i read them off
that dude common sense skeptic and then
there's like do we have any no there was
one he posted today which is so funny
was like i'm not understanding my tesla
model y ran me over
why would it do
this then like
people are just replying like because
it's not a good car you know there's
like another one where this kid's like
you know people don't even understand i
have a self-driving vehicle it's
autonomous i'm living in the future and
they
you know are living in the past or
whatever within days of posting that on
some other thread people are like yo
these are bad like they can [ __ ] kill
people he's like well they're not
self-driving it's just driving assisted
well which one is it no i heard ben and
emil explaining this on their most
recent episode so this is actually
really interesting there's fsd which is
full self-driving and in order to enable
that in your tesla you have to like take
a test and like i don't know be an elon
fanboy i guess yeah and then there's
autonomous driving or what the other one
autopilot sorry which isn't that's like
driver assisted yeah and so i guess
there's like horror stories from people
that have fsd enabled it's so funny how
anyone still thinks that guy that dude
is a con artist
in like the fullest degree elon yeah
yeah all the [ __ ] he's promised
literally none of his ideas have
worked minus tesla that's not even his
right i'm saying like he's just he took
something that someone else made and was
just like putting dollars into it yeah
the tunnel that dude has been for five
years saying it's gonna be done in five
years yeah what when was this when did
they start doing this september so like
almost a year
yeah oh a month ago there was this
hilarious video that came out about the
fsd like in a city oh we've got a
situation in front of us whoa whoa whoa
oh no no we're going on the wrong side
of the road whoa whoa whoa whoa no no no
dude it's just like going up to like
lamp poles and on sidewalks
it's like dude this [ __ ] is gonna kill
so many people although i will say if it
ever actually works
it would be insanely sick ben and emil
were like no one's gonna want to like
work on their commute to the office no
but you can at least you watch netflix
or some [ __ ] like that you can still do
that now
yeah i guess you can yeah you say that
like people don't [ __ ] drive like
this now i know that's true people are
looking at their phones already yeah so
one thing that's really interesting is
elon fans whenever
a tesla gets called out for bad [ __ ]
they're always like oh it's only over
teslas that are named by the vehicle
type in an article no other cars and
it's like that's not true it's like bmw
this and that you know it's like the
the loop like the hoops that these
people go through to defend this guy i
was like on some random ass subreddit
like
reading something about elon with like
nine [ __ ] comments and then all the
comments are like people are acting like
elon hasn't single-handedly done
the most influential things for the
environment uh in all of like human
history oh cars yeah and people are like
the [ __ ] are you talking about you know
what it takes to make one of those
batteries yeah and in five years you
have to buy two of them for your one
stupid car i don't know i just [ __ ]
hate him dang i just do it's not even
cause he's like a billionaire or
anything like that i just think he sucks
i think he's sick his hair is dope